foreign
[Applause]
happy Friday wearing my glasses tonight
maybe we'll win an Emmy
so let's take a look at all the things
that piss me off beside the looks I get
when I buy clothes in the boys
department
on my fault first Biden's ratings are so
far down the toilet they could wave
hello to Chris Wallace
it's so bad I hear Biden's new
strategist is Roto-Rooter
wow just a chuckle I thought that would
work so no wonder he's once again
talking up student loan forgiveness when
really Joe should be asking for
forgiveness not Doling it out
forgiveness for Afghanistan for tanking
the economy for farting in front of the
Royal Family
[Laughter]
that bomb was so ranked the queen
thought the Germans were blitzing again
now they want to forgive 10 grand or
roughly what Hunter paid for a weekend
of hookers
of course this is a Hail Mary pass or
for the gender-confused a hail Larry
cement to appeal to young voters before
the midterms which should crush the Dems
like a dozen eggs under Brian stelter's
box spring
wait did I say voters I met Democratic
voters the ones too dumb to realize
they're trading their future for a quick
payout so they're taking your money to
pay a bribe to people who hate you to
re-elect the same freaks who demonize
you daily it's a Democrat birthday party
and you're the pinata
but like geraldo's Ex-Wives these people
they don't need the money
[Laughter]
this isn't a food stamp program or
welfare it's transferring money from the
working class to the wealthy and upper
middle class who vacation in Aspen while
running up college debt as regular
people have to take second jobs or like
me who paid for college by making
deposits to sperm banks
some of it was my own
think of all
of the aocs of the world she's the
whiner who claims she can't live off six
figures as she Tools around at a Tesla
with her French Bulldog I think that was
her dog either that or her fiancee
they call you racist
which Tesla is hers it's the one
dragging an extension cord
foreign
but it's immoral it's theft I sound like
Pelosi while she's handing her Amex
cards or plastic surgeon
and if your blood isn't boiling over
this you must be deader than a former
Clinton associate
think of all those people who paid off
their student loans you know that's like
paying a hooker for sex then finding out
she's been giving it away to your
neighbors for free that's why we
divorced
gets worse house dams blocked a plan to
fund the police while receiving 10 grand
each to bulk up their home security see
it's that 10 grand again why because
they assume everyone will just call it
chump change but who's the chump it's us
because we're paying for the security of
people who refuse to grant us the same
safety during thanks to them the worst
crime wave in my lifetime you know
what's that old saying don't pee on my
leg and tell me it's raining that's not
strong enough how about don't take a
dump on my head and tell me it's a
Mudslide
[Laughter]
I'm disgusting all of you what but
remember while cities were burning and
cops were getting killed they said let's
have less police the Kama Sutra doesn't
have this many ways to screw people
now you
now you see why these Crooks got into
the business so they could be exempt
from the punishment they enact on others
they can screw you but you can't screw
them back Al Capone had nothing on these
people politics aren't as organized as
crime gets at least the gangsters didn't
pretend to be helping you while robbing
you blind but this is how it works they
create laws for us and not them Gavin
Newsom met friends for lunch while the
rest of La had to wrap themselves up
like mummies the president's son has a
life that would make Charlie Sheen blush
Nancy Pelosi's husband strolled away
from a DUI but I guess if I were coming
home to Nancy I'd knock back a few shots
of kerosene
and finally a senior FBI agent allegedly
tried to pad the number of domestic
violence violent extremism cases meaning
as we suspected they were gaslighting us
and not in the fun way that involved a
trip to Taco Bell and flicking a big
lighter an hour later
okay
so while real crime raged they imagined
a threat that would end up hopefully
being you it's no surprise they already
targeted parents trumpers anyone near
the capitol of January 6. I'm surprised
that they haven't gone after me and I'm
glad they haven't I would not survive
prison I'd be one of the prizes in a
card game
I'd become someone's [ __ ] faster than
Colbert became bidens
so what's good for the goose is good for
the gander
said the guy zipping his fly as he
approached a very scared gander
I feel dirty you too yes
but we need to make sure they feel the
consequences of their actions and how we
got to play their game once the
Republicans take the house if they want
to bribe people with your money let's do
the same with their money get all those
gender studies grads to pay for your pet
projects how about NRA instruction
courses for teachers how about funding
the student instead of the school so
people have a real choice in education
and let's Embrace load and forgiveness
but make the overpaid colleges refund
the doe defund the crap out of them they
have it coming you send Billy off to
Harvard at 73 Grand a year and he comes
home for Christmas with a new pronoun a
pair of homegrown boobs and a hatred for
America I'm thinking you got a raw deal
foreign
Billy
at
as for crime they applauded incoherent
mobs coming to Supreme Court Justices
homes which is ironic when the president
their biggest cheerleader can't even
find his own
meanwhile New York's idiot Governor
directed people to Lee zeldin's rallies
to disrupt them it's time for payback
what if the just released thugs made it
to the neighborhoods of progressive DA's
and anti-copt Dems
just put funds toward halfway houses
right next to theirs make Alvin Bragg or
George gascon have to worry about crime
just like you do you know it's working
right now with immigration all those
phony Sanctuary cities now must walk the
walk it's time for a taste of their
medicine I mean isn't that how vaccines
work
so drop your pants and bend over
Democrat politicians
this won't hurt very much I promise
period
let's welcome tonight's guests he worked
his way up from beat reporter by
savagely beating other reporters Fox
News contributor in Washington Times
opinion editor Charlie hurt foreign
she thinks it's a trifle to carry two
Glocks and a rifle townhall.com editor
and host of luxury hunting Lodges of
America on Fox Nation Katie Pavlich
her classmates called her teacher's pet
because she kept biting everyone oh yeah
yeah Fox News contributor cat Tim
[Applause]
and he once gave the Tooth Fairy a
hernia my massive sidekick in the NWA
World Television Champion Tyron
foreign
great to see you as always great to see
you Greg yeah
yeah thank you there's a lot of facets
to that brilliant monologue I just
recited uh care to address any one of
them well truly uh you know and I I do
think that you're on to something here
um a big reason why the uh Biden
Administration is talking about wanting
to bail out uh student loans is because
Democrat Party has become the the party
of privileged white college educated
people and it's all part of a a much
larger realignment uh that we're seeing
in the political parties I think it's
personally I think it's a good thing but
um but they are terrified and there is
no amount of money that they wouldn't
pay pay to to uh to buy off a new set of
Voters but they should be you know
anybody should be aware that it's kind
of interesting uh with how the
Democratic party has for 40 years been
on this project to bring uh to woo
Hispanic voters and as soon as they find
out that Hispanic voters don't like them
they're like call in the National Guard
let's build the wall let's be done with
so anybody thinking about getting into
bed with the Democrats should be aware
of that yes
yes especially if they're Hunter Biden
wow you'll be coming back with a lot of
different boxes you know that's true
um
Hunter pox we should do a segment called
Fox News yeah
wait I think we did I was like I'm
pretty sure we have yeah I think we did
one of those I think we were there first
Haiti so we have uh to to Charlie's
point we have Muriel Bowser Muriel
Bowser the complaining they have the
National Guard there because now their
Sanctuary city is literally now a
sanctuary City how did this happen I
don't know is there a way that we can do
the same thing with other issues because
I think like the halfway house thing is
a solution well the first thing I would
say is on the student loan bailout
Democrats would be very terrified of
what I call the d3s the deranged woke
white women because they are the most
dangerous creatures we have in this
country and they will scream at you in
their Lululemon pants all day long
especially if you're a black cop you do
that too
um so it's just a payoff for their base
and people who get very loud on media
but yes this is happening in DC I
remember when Donald Trump wanted to
send the National Guard to the actual
border and the left freaked out said it
was xenophobic it was racist and now all
of a sudden sudden people start showing
up at Union Station and all the homeless
shelters in DC which is also a huge
problem get filled up and then reality
hits these mares in the face and it's
like Oh you mean there are only limited
resources for a certain number of people
so now they want to build a tent city
yeah DC and have the National Guard come
process people so again they're building
cages and then they'll blame it on
Republicans cloth cages cloth cages yes
the worst kind yes yeah it's interesting
though because my those people are
actually coming there to work and
they're going to have the national guard
against people working as opposed to
like during riots during those riots in
Seattle or or Portland Oregon Tyrus what
did you uh what do you think of the
points I'm making care to offer your
Keen observations well I believe the
original saying was don't piss down my
back and tell me it's rain and you have
turned it into something
I don't think anyone will ever say that
again really yeah I think you've changed
the game
thank you forever be an image the only
good news is right before I could
process that you
got even creepier so
I'm still thinking about the whole
sometimes it was mine comment so in
between the
ridiculously inappropriate creepy
comments you made some really solid
points oh thank you oh it's just hard to
sift through sometimes I like to get
people to think you did you did but when
you're regurgitating and thinking it's
difficult
which regurgitating is pretty good
because that's what the woke are doing
right now because we always say it's not
a problem when you're unaffected right
you can say anything and everyone's a
racist xenophobic until it's in your
yard and now it's in their yard and if I
was
governor of Texas or Arizona or border
state I would be like let's get more
buses right let's get more things going
and I would start having Billboards
beautiful Washington DC where the
streets are full of jobs and money and
free health care and I would just arrows
pointing that way and I would just keep
them going just keep them sending you
know I would you know cat I would love
to replace every politician with a with
a migrant worker 10 of them we would get
so much more stuff done I mean we can
I'm down to just try anything at this
point well you can try something new yes
that's kind of your Mo yeah
I'm a curious person you are you're a
curious cat there's nothing wrong with
that except for all the times it's gone
horribly wrong
not to bring up another old saying but
curiosity killed the cat yes I am still
alive somehow I'm waiting for him
it's amazing
thing they could try is maybe try not
spending all their time trying to figure
out new things to spend money on but
they don't think of that because they
don't take responsibility for what
they're doing and if you're not asking
those questions oh where did I maybe
must mess up here it's not going to be
obvious that you're continuing to you
know have the same problem over and over
again I don't think we should print more
money for student loan debt that's
absurd especially because the more money
that goes into it the colleges have no
reason to not keep charging more and
more and more and more and more it's
just going to keep getting worse yeah
the tuition I think tripled over the
last three decades because nobody
bothered to pump the brakes it's an
analogy yeah and and I really do think
that it would be a tremendous uh uh
contribution to the country if somebody
did put together a massive class-action
lawsuit to go after these universities
that teach nonsense and teach total
Bumpus that doesn't get you anything in
the world in terms of a job uh but and
get and make them pay some of the only
problem is the only people who do cash
action lawsuits are liberals yeah I know
conservatives are too busy actually
creating things rather than taking
things well they should tax the
endowments of all these universities and
let them bail out the student loans are
huge they're huge and there's no
incentive for these universities to
actually get people jobs when they leave
because they're public universities so
there's no return on investment and then
they want us to bail them out well let's
hold on to Car Wash Biden doesn't
remember much but he seems to remember
not to bring this into action yes I keep
saying next month yeah I'm working on it
uh yeah whatever things are yeah badly
he's like hey I know he likes to play
Kick the Can Way Way Back in prehistoric
times but he's kicking the can on that
one because he's not a dummy that's too
a can well sure yeah all right hey Sean
Hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to Fox News YouTube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else